[Music]
all right so I have taken over my wife's
position the anchor for this show a boy
can do it better so we've all been
shuttered inside the den wait no
sheltered and sheltered yeah
shunned ins basically yeah so we've all
been sheltered in and I feel like we've
all been doing different things to pass
the time
yeah he's been jacking off a lot he said
yes and he's also been live streaming
have you seen his wife yeah I've seen it
thank you compassion stuff I went in I
was like hey Joe and Steve and I'm so
happy and they got ignore come back in
again and I was all recognizing what are
we talking about and we were probably
not even focusing in the chat my
all-night friends were like oh hi Gio hi
chew it was like all these comments to
GOP there's so many comments in your
name and then there's so many comments
that are also asking Joe one particular
question and Joe you never answered in
the live stream so I want to ask you
here on JK news Oh juicy is your dad
alive by the time this video goes up a
video of me explaining the whole
backstory between me and my dad and all
that but people who they get this
because there's been a Jay King news
episode where you know I talk about like
you know my dad might be dead I don't
[ __ ] know and I mean you were there
Steve was there and they were like wait
that's so anticlimactic why don't you
just butchered the [ __ ] out of it okay
tell what this is what the [ __ ] happened
Sookie so Joe fashion right he's kind of
chill like the way he is he goes oh him
know my dad's live anymore yes you know
what I was and he moves on
Oh like everyone literally get like gasp
cuz it's your dad you know so what we're
just like mom the context of it because
will told you guys well I expect I'm
expecting him to die any minute you
smile when you're saying this I told
your ass I don't know the context okay
why told you guys that like he's
basically okay before that right the
audience doesn't know that I'm talking
to him because I always talk [ __ ] about
him like as a joke right like so this is
what they don't know dad
oh man Oh Julia's been gone this entire
to like I said by the time this video
goes up everything's gonna be on my
channel for the whole scope but recap
for Julia recap for people that don't
know what's going on is so for 20-plus
years I haven't talked to my dad right
yeah yeah
so there's another thing where you know
TIFF had like something with her dad and
she was just we had a heart-to-heart and
she's like man I think it'll be a great
opportunity for you to do it cuz you're
gonna miss out that's tenant so whatever
right so I was like honestly TIFF I was
like I made my closure so whether he's
dead or alive
I don't do it look you know and she's
like I think you should still do it it's
alright alright you know what it doesn't
hurt to just try it
to see and you know what maybe it's not
for me but maybe it's for him because
even if I feel cool about it maybe he
needs to hear that like hey I forgive
you I don't give a [ __ ] it's cool man
and so we met up and this sentimental
[ __ ] chooses a Redondo Beach
Pier where we used to go fishing a lot
of he's like who know he was doing it so
unintentionally I knew what his [ __ ]
plans were he's all like hey madam we
should go eat lunch cuz because I called
him right before I got to get that so
okay so damn I'm all okay before I meet
up with them yeah I was under the
impression that he didn't want to meet
any of us that he wanted to forget about
the family and he was done with it and
that's what I told TIFF to cuz I was
like you know what
I don't think he wants to see me so we
made closure on that part she goes ah
but you should try it so I act I call my
aunt cuz my aunts been keeping in
contact with them and my dad told my I
don't contact him anymore so that's the
message I got is that he didn't want to
talk to the rest of us so I said hey I
don't know how he's doing I know he
recently was on dialysis like he lost a
couple of fingers a piano fell on you
look like it's like nah dude like he has
normal like it looks it looks like
Yakuza like oh he's missing he's missing
these two fingers like here oh you think
it was a coozer
he probably the Adamic never play a
piano again because of pianos it looks
like a mafia because his two fingers
right here are cut off so it's like you
made two mistakes dawg that's a really
failed gangster joke no no but it looks
like a mafia because the piano fall onto
his fingers is that what he has oh yeah
oh yeah cause it was more believable
only four years old his whole body it
fell on his hand he had to dislocate his
fingers oh that's why it's okay that's
why to me it's funny to just say a piano
fell on my dad it's like it's like a
cartoon hope I know we gotta follow the
thought process cuz normally it would be
like oh I'm so sorry but yeah we forget
I give the joke before the thought
process so I was under the impression
that he didn't want to talk to me or the
family right so I told my art because my
aunt got news that he wasn't doing so
well in his health a lot of bad things
went down all this [ __ ] so after that I
was just like you know what call him up
for me and see if he wants to talk and
then she was like yeah she's like he
does want to talk to you
right I was like all right cool so we
catch up on the phone and basically he's
telling me like I asked him I was like I
thought you don't want to talk to any of
us he goes no I don't want to talk to
your ah oh I wanted to talk to you and
your brother
oh so you say it but your dad says the
name for my aunt is actually auntie so
aunt auntie auntie yeah yes it's my yeah
yeah okay so anyways so he calls her
that basically it's his sister-in-law
right but but he says yeah I don't want
to talk to them because it's just
memories and it's just kind of awkward
and like that part of my life is just
weird he goes but I do want to talk to
you and your brother and I I just felt
like not worthy of talking to you guys
and I was like [ __ ] well this whole time
I thought you rejected the family and
he's like nah man like that's not the
case and I was like okay well [ __ ] it
let's be friends and [ __ ] and then he
was like alright so we had dinner I mean
we had lunch and this is with a funny
ass sneaky sentimental [ __ ] like
he goes hey man like you heard a Redondo
Beach I'm like heard of it like we
[ __ ] education they're like every
week man and then he's like yeah let's
go get some seafood man let's go let's
go hang out so we go and we eat there
and it was just like old friends like
hanging out again no hard feelings you
know he's all like oh there's not a day
that goes by where I don't [ __ ]
regret you know this whole thing and he
was like I pray for you every night just
this and that and then he's just like
man I think I did so much to ruin or
make your life hard basically yeah I was
just showing him all the [ __ ] that I be
reading up to and he's all like damn
he's like whoa it was funny because in
between that he was like hey man it
sounds like you're talking like you're a
has-been and I'm like what do you mean
and he goes yeah it sounds
you're kind of like you feel like you're
at the end of your life but I think
you're just started and I'm all I don't
know what he was talking about but it
maybe I did come off as though like I
didn't know what I was gonna do because
at that time I was still at jazz I
wasn't in the good place mentally maybe
but maybe I was spewing this [ __ ] and I
didn't know and he's like put it into
perspective he's like you ready
accomplished way more than I did at your
age she was at the same age that you're
at 35 years old he was that's when I
came to America and decided that I'm
gonna pursue music and he's like before
that he's like yeah I was kind of all
over the place so it was you already at
your age like built this company media
company you you're employing people you
have a team you have friends that you're
close with all this stuff and he's like
and he's like I didn't even get to
starting until your age he goes at 35 I
set foot into America and I started from
scratch so he goes you you just started
and you and I'm like oh [ __ ] you just
really put things into perspective for
me that's a good dad advice my daddy for
a deadbeat dude he's a [ __ ] good
things to say 20 years yeah so this fool
you know he's only got three of he's
missing three fingers he can't sing
anymore cuz he has diabetes his livers
all [ __ ] up he's on dialysis but he
told me he has the will to live now he's
happy all the [ __ ] right but this guy's
life is just constantly [ __ ] up so um
we go back and forth on the fall we try
to catch up again and I said hey you
know what let's jam out on some music
it's been some time I know you can't
play anymore but you could at least
teach me I always wanted to continue
piano singing all that stuff so it goes
yeah let's do it man
and then um I go okay I'm gonna go to
Europe come back I'm [ __ ] sick right
remember I was sick for like two months
maybe I did have the cool thing you had
the coffee yeah I don't know and then
I'm I'm healed I go back out again right
right before I go out I text them like
an article and you know whatever and
then the text says no Richard which is
his name no Richard right I'm like no
Richard what the [ __ ] so I was like oh
he's probably dead
cuz I was ready for him it just died any
day and I kept telling them on the phone
I'm like you better not [ __ ] die I
just saw your ass now I know why people
are asking is your dad dead because
initially I was like dude that's like
hella personal and like kind of
insensitive it's no big deal for me so
the thing is initially because I had no
context whatsoever I made peace so
here's the thing like I made peace with
him just to me now every day that he's
alive it's extra credit yeah I made
peace that this dude was dead 20 years
ago on top of that my relationship to
him is not the same as your relationship
to your parents like for me I've only
had him up till I was like 13 so I spent
most of my life without him so to me
yeah it's like an old friend and I feel
this like if it was my mom oh man like
that would be a completely different
story I wouldn't be laughing about her
dime right but in this case there's a
bit of pain is because I'm like you
[ __ ] up will you [ __ ] up as a dad so
I'm gonna laugh at you a little bit you
know me is it's it's just a mixed
emotion that I have but um so during
that time we're we're eating we're
hanging out and I mean this is how bold
I am like I was like you know what if I
were just to see you a year ago and I
saw you on the street I would have
[ __ ] smack you in the face
like I would've decked your mouth and
then he's all like well deserved we're
talking right I'm all hey can I take a
picture of your hair and he's like why
he goes cuz I want to show my friends
that you're a part of the mob he's like
no and it was like I will just take a
picture with me right so we got the
waiter to take a picture of us and I was
like can we take a picture like this
he's like none and he's all like he's he
in the picture he has his hand around
his back like yeah
cuz you got self-conscious right and I
just wanted a picture like this so you
can see the three fingers and [ __ ] yeah
but yeah so okay fast forward right I
mean I right before I go to Europe I get
the text and I think he's dead
some like the bug all right I'm like
well I'm about to go to a happy place
I'm gonna go on vacation like I don't
want to deal with this [ __ ] so I'll
hit him up again when I get back
while I'm in Europe I get a text from
him and then he's like hey can I please
talk to you I need a chance I'm like the
[ __ ] I never not gave you a chance so I
take them back I'm all like I can't cuz
I'm on Wi-Fi like I'm also traveling in
Europe right now and I'm like so what is
it and he goes uh it's about power of
attorney right somehow yeah I'm like
okay well attorney kind of like being in
charge of all of his [ __ ] got it yeah
like when you can't make you legally
like he could legally do like deposits
with real money like make decisions on
his bad got it
yeah so I was like thinking well first
of all you have nothing to your goddamn
name you broke-ass [ __ ] so what are you
gonna leave like you don't have anything
to leave
so anyways um I take them back I'll be
like I'll be back at this time and then
the chaos happens right I'm just focused
on getting back to America I get back
and I totally forget because I have no
food in the house I'm trying to
quarantine all this stuff and then I
finally get to talk to him and he says
yeah I just got out of a coma but the
next time I was wondering if you could
be in charge of my life Oh so do you
want to live or die enough yeah cuz I
was like have you thought about it and
he's like not really and I'm like
alright so I'm cool with it I'll just
give the doctor my number and I was like
I'll be in charge of your life just tell
me do you want to live or do you want to
die and he's like well shoot I haven't
thought about it right and he goes well
maybe if I had a chance of survival I
want to fight for it cuz he's waiting
for a liver transplant and then I was
like but what if it's like 30% chance of
survival and you also
then at that case like I don't want to
[ __ ] like be a burden I'm like cool
what do you want me to do with your
stuff he goes I got a bunch of like
pictures of music stuff I was like can I
keep it
he's like yeah and then I was like you
have anything else about you videos now
if you have anything of value I'm like
so who's gonna sort this [ __ ] out he
goes why I kinda have someone that I've
been a father figure to and she's been
taking care of me and I'm like oh cool
alright so um yeah everything was kind
of settled and then at this point I'm
like dude I was like I told him I was
like this kind of sucks like I'm in
charge of your life and we just had
lunch once Wow dude you're gonna [ __ ]
croak and I have to bury your ass and he
goes not try to take care of everything
before I go and I'm all ok well that's
cool
and then he's like you still want to do
music lessons and I'm like yeah but you
got to stay alive for that but before
this our conversations were pretty
hilarious to just is my childhood like
he's like one of those guy like he's
like those eccentric artists that have
no social skills so I think that's where
a lot of my craziness sometimes come but
he's like he'll interpret you say Joe
he's not blunt though as me he's more
reserved Oh like I get it I get that
from my grandma but anyways so another
thing happens like man I just feel so
bad for the dude I think that's why I
don't have the capacity to be angry at
him cuz his life just constantly keeps
sucking so he's been living with his
girlfriend for like [ __ ] 20-something
years and he doesn't want to give her
power of attorney she passed exactly
you know [ __ ] tired I'm tired exactly
right so this is like a week ago and I'm
in the middle quarantine so my two-week
quarantine right this or no no yeah yeah
over this is over a week ago but he he
[ __ ] text he just calls in text and
I'm just like man you thirsty ass [ __ ]
I don't want to talk to you and then so
um I just decided to finally pick up my
phone right and then he's like yeah so
my girlfriend just passed and I'm like
oh I was like was it the corona and he's
like no I wasn't the corona is like
she's been having cancer and I'm like oh
so you were expecting it and he's like
yeah and I'm like okay so what went down
and was well she died in her sleep but
last night she wasn't feeling so well
and I was like you want the ambulance
and she's like no I try to sleep it off
and in the morning she just didn't wake
up just some [ __ ] like that you know and
and I guess she was already going
through a lot I know right it's pretty I
was like damn I was like thinking your
life sucks you should have never left me
dude no but but literally that's what he
called me for and I'm like so how are
you doing and then at the same time I'm
like look I'm trying to deliver lemons
right now like I don't know what I'm
supposed to do Joe I had friends that
wanted lemons so so so I'm talking to
him in the car
cuz I'm driving off and I'm like hold on
you know like I gotta get my lemons in
the car I'm talking [ __ ] and then
something like what are you gonna do
like you know as well I don't know if I
could pay the pills and I'm like I'm
giving you money dude oh and it's like
no no that's not what I called for
he's like I'm just kind of like in a
situation and I'm like well do you have
anybody that can at least take care of
you that's when I found out about the
whole like no no no like like her
daughter was really you know someone
that he's been in there and he's she's
been taking care of my dad back so I had
a question about that so like I know
that this could be maybe because you and
him are blood related but like how come
he didn't give her the power to like the
blood related thing like he never
married remarried she
never like you know I just don't that I
guess the doctor told them that the
easiest way to deal with it is just kin
but I don't even know like why can't you
just lie and say that girls I don't know
yeah I really don't know he comes up
with stupid [ __ ] like he told me you
know what I did I cleared out all my
debt because when I'm dead it doesn't go
on to my sons and I'm like you could
have just died you idiot like I didn't
want to say that cuz I didn't want to
make him feel like he worked so hard but
in my heart I was like well I did
mention it of the bells like I don't
think you can it can be passed down to
me and my brother with all the daddy
goes yeah I can cuz I [ __ ] worked
hard I had all this ready the Mafia and
that no I was just it was like credit
card debt and [ __ ] like that that [ __ ]
gets excused if you just die you know it
doesn't pass down next to kin but in his
head he was like doing this thing that
was so stupid cuz I'm like that's not
how [ __ ] works well it was Noble and
it was like it's admirable that he did
something to the kind of right yeah I
guess I don't know okay Joe's face no
it's not some backstory all right so one
of the reasons why he left the house is
he was he had this hero's journey of
life I have so much dad he goes I need
to go out clear this [ __ ] out
and then come back to you guys right and
then that's what his whole goal was oh
he he's like he's like and he's like 74
right it was it was at 70 years old he's
like I finally cleared it I don't have
to and then I'm thinking man some people
work their lives for something that's
meaningless and this is one of those
things dude one of those things because
he worked [ __ ] hard for something and
then like as I got older I realized hold
the [ __ ] up that's not how that works
man it doesn't pass on to your children
he didn't ask anyone who just thought
that's how it is that's how he is dude
so that's why I'm making this whole
power of attorney [ __ ] he probably could
get her to be the legal guardian because
he has a closer connection
yeah but he's like da has to
the Sun it has to be blood-related man
and your brother won't talk to me
you know sometimes when people get a
present they're like you know it's the
thought that counts
this is not one of those times content
does not matter here but it's just it's
just it just sucks like I think that his
situation sucks so bad but also I don't
know if I'm a dick but I feel like I
don't want to deal with the extra
[ __ ] look I think you're being a
dick I want to bury him I don't want to
clean out his house like I don't want to
do any of this stuff I mean if he wasn't
around yeah well she's not even a dick I
just feel bad for the dude but it's
almost like a stranger that I have to do
all this extra work for yeah yeah I
don't think you're being a dick maybe
you just gotta convince him for the
doctor yeah yeah I think that's what's
gonna end up happening but then I don't
even I don't even really want to call
the pot like get a doctor call be like
yeah like do you want to pull the plug
cuz the first answer is yes I am I'm
gonna say yes cuz I don't want to keep
him alive and have to deal with other
[ __ ] but that's I don't know and that's
where the in sensitiveness maybe might
come out cuz I'm just being selfish no I
mean it makes sense so cuz he's been
like away from you for so many years and
you just don't really have much of an of
an emotional attachment to him yeah it
feels like I have to do it's like I'm
burying your guys's parent or something
but then hey you like my mom that's true
I probably take care of a better
situation
I understand where I'm at right now man
and I don't really know how to navigate
but yeah I'm till I'm bringing y'all
into my lives by the time this video
goes up there's probably like a full
backstory of my relationship with the
dude and yeah man there's phone
conversations and it's also I don't know
pictures and everything no pictures of
hands so he's still alive he's still
alive all the options answered yeah he's
still alive and strong and he wants to
sing some songs and [ __ ] crazy scores
later a crazy story man pretty mad huh
[Music]